combien de sales gamins aujourd'hui je
ne qualifierais pas nos étudiants de
sales gamins les futurs diplômés se
sentent souvent sous pression ce qui
favorise des comportements irrationnels
monsieur clark dans mon bureau je suis
venu parce que j'ai envie de bien faire
jésus marie joseph et ça va être le clac
quoi on est encore et on n'est pas dans
un de ses films à la con dégoulinant de
bons sentiments
cette jolie porte que vous voyez au fond
restera fermé jusqu'à mon retour
et quand il revint les murs étaient
couverts de sang s'affère à part bon va
très bien je vous laisse ce général
andrew winston clark a volé territoire
d'une tribu apache qui plus tard est
devenu crestview on pourrait vérifier si
cet endroit vraiment et si vous étiez un
peu crus esprits montre nous ta présence
une présence ici avec nous je la sens
verte a contrarié ici de terre je suis
persuadé que vous pourrez survivre tous
les 6 pendant huit heures ça arrive tous
les ans quel que soit l'établissement
les étudiants nous s'en prennent à leurs
parents même aux uns et aux autres
qu'est ce que tu fous ici
c'est un miracle qu'ils ne s'entretuent
pas